what is going on there reject nation we
are going to watch today the boys season
3 finale i am so excited to see how this
season wraps up it has been stellar
stellar maybe we'll rank it after we're
done reacting to it but guys please
leave a like that helps us out on the
algorithm very much so also subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when uh reaction or some other
video is up here on the channel that
peaks your interest full length watch
along where you sync up with a time code
meaning use your own copy for the boys
or over at our patreon page i want to
thank each and every one of you who has
supported us by becoming a super sexy
reject by joining our patreon page we
cover a bunch of shows over there we're
at the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included the prepper team thank you so
much for helping us edit down these
highlights over the weeks and also want
to give a mention that any of our like
commentary review tracks all those get
uploaded to our podcast which you can
find the real rejects over at apple
spotify anywhere where podcasts are
found and lastly thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring us for each
one of these boys reactions you have
saved us in times of age restriction
videos and yellow dollar bill signs
there's been plentiful when it comes to
the boys so thank you guys for uh
supporting us throughout this journey
anywho let's see how this all wraps up
[Music]
oh
i knew your fastball would come in
sooner or later oh [ __ ] stay away from
him okay i'm not here to cause trouble
just want to see my son and i had a heck
of a time trying to find you buddy i
even had to get a big important
congresswoman to help me oh my god damn
you have a real family
aren't you mad at me oh no
for what i did
when you're as strong as
we are
accidents happen but but that's all it
is
an accident and nobody on this earth
knows that better than me
oh you're a good homelander
that's why i'm always going to love you
i'm not going anywhere i will always be
here
yikes
damn it yikes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
god's guns and homelander and she's on
her way here right now with a search
warrant to look for her
what are they gonna move her
please tell me they're just gonna move
her
come on maeve break out of there
superhero
breakout a lot worse
damn
not for those guys
homelanders shocking admissions on
starlight's instagram live feed led to
the largest single day drop in the
history of vaught
like i was scared there
deep and i
had to move maeve out of the tower
you were there
you were there
[Music]
rolling with back up
so worried black noir is going to die
where is maeve now
you are hey
bro
we're just gonna we're gonna go
oh he can't even spell soldier properly
you really are i spin the image of my
little brother
what
he'll never get out
you've only ever been about yourself i'm
sorry i'll make it right how every time
you try you make it worse ouch
i said get the [ __ ] out of my house i
don't want to murder her in the same
house with my kid
god damn it
don't touch me
don't come back here
how could he ever make it right goddamn
somebody walking away at this point did
he tell you
tell me what
that tempy is fatal
if you shot up anymore you'd probably be
dead right now that [ __ ] saved my
life
[Laughter]
she stopped me from taking more v
in his own messed up way i spent so much
time thinking he was
a loser
you know what dad
was there
taking care of me during during the
worst days of his life just trying to
keep the lights on and a
roof above our heads wow finally
appreciate him he wasn't weak
i just i didn't know
what strength was
oh
i i never should have put any of this
onto you
thank you for saying that but go [ __ ]
yourself
hey maeve
good to see you again glad you're okay
it's like you wear a neon sign that says
raw dog me i'm a bottle i'm gonna let
you two catch up
no shame and bottom and huey
yeah nina was right my papa i put a
chain around my neck and all that
[ __ ] changes is who holds the other
end
oh
what do you see
[Music]
[ __ ]
there are a couple thousand people in
that building
i mean if he pulls a hirogasm he's going
to take the whole [ __ ] place down we
take down soulja boy before he gets to
homeland they wouldn't have an orgy
there
they probably got a whole floor for
orgies i went to boarding school
got kicked out of boarding school
because i was a fuck-up
and he made sure i knew it he was a belt
did he
never laid a hand on me he couldn't be
bothered oh
and they got me into dr vox compound v
trials
i became a superhero strongest man alive
[ __ ] ticker tape parades when i came
home and what did the old man sight in
he said i took a shortcut oh god of
course he did ugh i'm linda right yours
he's the only blood i've got left it
doesn't matter
you didn't name him didn't raise him
he's a [ __ ] reason they left you to
roll with the ivins
we had a deal
i would have hammered home the the point
you were already making first
[Laughter]
move him there
yeah
you were in his team
you knew him
what was he like
he always wanted his father i was
wondering come on nobody's all bad
he's my father
wow wowie
i ripped apart the company archives and
it's true
it's true oh god
now
did you
who never had know
father out there oh no
don't alive this whole time
[Music]
oh god damn it black no hard
oh
[ __ ] oh no no no
damn it
what did you tell me
god dammit
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[ __ ]
oh
god you're the only one of the seven i'm
sad to see die
dammit watch him live through this
so worried that was gonna happen
we are so proud of you
[Music]
soon you'll be in the sweet embrace of
kkk
christ the lord
oh
jesus
[Music]
oh show us jesus so worried that was
going to happen
second he showed back up in this episode
[ __ ] me
she was dead
hey you didn't think i knew where the
blind spots were [ __ ]
back up
oh god
soldier boy goes through with this
thousands will die becca worked in the
tower you shut your [ __ ] keiko
frenchie
no
you will never commend me again i am
done with your cruelty okay i deserve
respect and we all deserve paid vacation
days and again
go frenchy
and a 401k unionized friendship
butcher's right homelander needs to die
that's it whatever it takes
i don't want to hurt you but i will
oh oh god oh no oh god
think about
i don't trust soldier boy nope
not an inch
we ran it through the voice thingamabob
it's really her so
you know i think we should probably
evacuate nobody's evacuating anything we
have to project strength
right no that's smart strength
are you pathetic loser
such excellent delivery
you know when the company first rolled
me out in front of the cameras they told
me
i was gonna get my very own team i
wanted so badly for that team to be the
family that i never got
and then i got
you oh my god
ashley take off that brick
what wig oh oh no ashley no
oh she's pulled her hair out so much
hasn't oh ashley
yes wowie
if dakota bob taps me for vp i'd be
honored
off the record
i'm expecting good news at the prayer
breakfast
homelander's so mean
[Laughter]
he's my role model
[Applause]
deep do that that's my guess
it's like the movie species
there is one lab in new york
that might be stoked with the things i
need and this fate would have it we are
headed there so you're joking we're
gonna break in the vault
yes
and you're gonna cook up the world's
most dangerous neurotoxin with what
little moxie and the little mr wizard
know-how while we
hold off homelander and soulja boy
the most important [ __ ] of my life
and i'm counting on coked out euro trash
hey be nice to frenchy he he grew as a
character just now
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh come on i bring it
okay
yeah
you never know
where's noir i killed him
because he didn't tell me about you
i know what it's like to have your team
betray you but with you and i together
they wouldn't stand a chance nobody
would family business
get ryan in on it too he ain't your kid
yes i am i am your son i am your blood
that's all that matters god damn
maybe
oh god i'm so on it
ugh this is your grandson
ryan
this is my son ryan your grandson
no
[ __ ] god damn it no not the g word
you're a family you have him
and you have me oh you're so clever the
shame that i've missed
so much
i wish i could have raised you
oh
maybe if i'd raised you
i could have made you better
oh my god
oh no
weak
sniveling [ __ ]
becoming your dad
but there's no fixing that her smile
oh my god
wow
get out of building now
get back upstairs
right now
this is the worst case scenario
not with the kid there though
brian
ah crap
no crap
oh man this is so bad
no i can't believe this is happening my
two dads
i did not see this coming at all not the
kid i thought you said blood didn't
matter but that was a whole [ __ ]
point he's my wife's son everything you
wanted he's right [ __ ] there
and now you blink stand down [ __ ] you
you're weaker than he is
god damn it homelander help him fight
would you yeah
hey [ __ ]
not now maeve we have bigger fish i
don't
yeah i've been said not now
come on maeve god damn maeve are you
trying to get yourself killed get a few
good licks in at least
[Music]
there we go there we go there has been a
terrorist threat called into the
building please leave as quickly as you
can this is not a drill this is not a
test where are you going ashley with you
ashley to the helipad yeah so the
sikorsky is actually reserved for svps
and higher
wow sorry ashley leave as quickly as you
can oh it's fine i'll just sprint to the
bottom of this high-ass tower homelander
you
you evil genius
[Music]
nice work
nice work
oh damn
god damn it's nice to get a good fight
yeah
my own blood
one eye patch it'll be okay
oh god
i don't know why you've never seen them
hotter than now
yeah man it's that unbridled fury
oh my god
a little excessive but yeah sure why not
you know
there's more need to release more people
[Music]
no
no
no
nice
oh you broke his shield
god damn it that hurts
oh
no no
oh no
no no no no no no no no oh he's gonna be
up
it's the only way
oh my god is this gonna happen
think faster huey
[Music]
oh
charger up nice
star god ah sargasm
[Music]
that's called supporting your woman
[Laughter]
no no
[Music]
just gets right back up son of a [ __ ]
you ain't no hero you're just another
racist piece of [ __ ] we can't seem to
get rid of this is one of my family
god damn
[Music]
no
[Music]
oh no no
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god
ah she did it
oh maeve
both black noir and maeve holy [ __ ]
here we go again
i want to go
let's leave
please
wow what a reversal from last season
[Music]
please
how long ago
months
12
18 on the outside
you can kind of [ __ ] off then
it's me
are you
there yes
you look like
[ __ ] [ __ ] off smurfette
soldier boys alive somewhere should i
get a pirate patch or the sammy davis
glass eye oh the pirate patch no
question
yeah you ready
hey
oh my god she came back dang
where will you guys go i know somewhere
homelander won't find me
into a bunker
you're like a
walking homework hard enough
bye
oh
bye maeve and then homelanders just
right outside the doors
[Music]
god damn it ashleys
[Music]
yes
yes
finally grew one spinal column
[Music]
don't worry someone will thaw him out at
some point
[Music]
go cassandra
i don't need it
i don't the suit never gave me any power
and thought sure [ __ ] didn't
definitely should have burnt it we're in
a historic building you need to double
knot okay and bag your trash
if you're gonna be working here butcher
isn't gonna like it
bucha can suck my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
after the tragic drowning of presumptive
vp candidate lamar bishop we go live to
the singer campaign in sioux falls where
dakota bob just announced his new
running mate
what would you like to say to the
american people oh christ yes as the
next vice president i will work hard to
provide a safe and secure future for all
citizens
i am so proud to have her on my team
we're going after the white house
that [ __ ]
is definitely gonna go
[ __ ] you and your eyes
[Applause]
coming to be with these people yep yep
hi good to see you i love you guys
you are america true patriots
hey
do you want to meet someone someone very
special to me oh christ you're not no
role model no are you really
oh you're sick son of a [ __ ]
this little guy here
is my son
ryan
god your points are gonna be through the
roof
wow
what's up todd
they're gonna cheer aren't they yup
[Applause]
oh no
no no no
oh great
no
wow
that is cruel and twisted
that makes sense
that's the way it would go yeah
well [ __ ]
i feel like they got like two more
seasons left in them
one or two at least
um
that was great that was an amazing
finale yeah
[ __ ] that was
i'm in a daze it's shocking that was a
lot of shocking shocking stuff in there
man there's a crescendo oh man
what's gonna become of ryan
he's gonna be fine
all right let's chitty chatty
before we do a word from today's video
sponsor
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is this is quite
affordable they have multiple
subscription levels to suit your exact
needs whether you're an independent
indie solo creator or a whole team so if
you want to learn more head on down to
our link in the description box and get
started that's at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
all right
i'm gonna kick us off with first thing
to talk about john oh
jesus uh i mean what an ending to the
the freaking season i mean the way that
they have managed like it's i think it's
hard
it takes probably a lot of ingenuity in
the writers room to figure out how to
keep a character like homelander ever
escalating and ever
sort of developing and warping in the
levels of depravity and just what a
threat he is to not only
people physically but also just as an
ideological symbol and
to watch
to watch the back and forth with ryan in
this episode was like especially sort of
heart crunching because they've already
done things surrounding you know
radicalization and and
uh how people who are a bit older and
who have a little more life experience
get indoctrinated into these things but
you know for for him as you know still
very much a child in a lot of ways and
having these
really conflicting experiences with
different guardians and father figures
like it
it's such a kind of heart-rending end
in that sense like ugh like the soul of
ryan like i have to imagine that in the
next season that's going to be a heavy
theme
because i mean you know you see it at
the end there he's not that vexed that
his dad just blew some nude's head up so
yeah
like yeah i feel like especially
building up soldier boy and like this
you know homelander scale threat
dealing with all that like this
definitely feels like at least for
soldier boy sort of an interstitial
piece like there can definitely be more
with him but just as the arc of again
homelander i feel like you come in every
season be like man where are they gonna
are they gonna keep him feeling like
this volatile you know horrific presence
and i think they they manage it here and
and especially with these emotional
curveballs that they throw
there were a lot of points especially
towards the end when like the three of
them are all in the same room together
grandfather son and grandson like
the the amount of emotional suspense
along with the physical stakes i thought
that was really great
yeah this whole season seemed to be
about
literally the inheriting the sins of
your father and how that's passed along
and uh how we all react
as as we go about our lives like a lot
of father and son themes was pretty much
the through line for everyone of
whatever inherited trauma there was even
write down like mother's milk inheriting
uh the the life experiences he's had
soldier boy you get to hear his
backstory of how he was treated and then
he quickly morphs into
adopting his father's
point of view while interacting with
homelander
and homelander you know i just think
anthony stars performance when he is
interacting with soldier boy just like
how he starts breaking down in front of
him i really
really love anthony stark's performance
because he can has a such a range of
just knowing each and every moment of
what this character is thinking and
feeling and then to
have a scene where
you're on the you're on the brink of
something very explosive and and then to
have him
literally succumb to tears
in front of ryan and
begging to be a family
in that moment and that's
kind of a through line for all these
characters as we've seen with butcher
from season two to especially this
season with exploring his past
so i think like thematically they all
kept it on board for how
they kept it on board for exactly
how each one of these people would
ultimately respond to situations and
it does leave it in a fascinating spot
for every one of them like
look i know people don't like to hear
this but homelanders trump all right
that's not my opinion it's pretty
obvious what they're doing and for all
you trump supporters out there that's
what they're they're doing today
yeah it's something that i've talked
with other people who do like videos on
the boys and
they actually try to refrain from saying
that they they they try to keep it out
because there's definitely going to be
redemption arc
like i don't want to stir this up turn
out good i don't want to stir something
up in the comments i don't want to and
it's like it's so obvious it's what
they're doing and they just know you
know who the filmmakers are involved in
creating this piece yeah you know it's
what they're commenting on
so whether you like it or not that's
what they're doing and especially in
those final moments you know uh what the
crowd is representing and the fact he
could do such a violent act and the
crowd will just cheer him on
be like yay we uplift you we support you
you're doing the thing the mainstream
wouldn't do you're going against it all
uh and it's it is that's the kind of
commentary i i tend to like no we
haven't seen trump murder a guy in front
of a crowd of people we haven't uh but
it's it's so obvious it's what what
they're doing and you'd be
naive to think that's not that's not
what they're commenting
um so that is it leaves it in a more
disgusting morbid place um for where
homelander
can play around it because
now he's at a spot where he just killed
in his last season
you know a big part when victoria newman
was going up against homelander in the
public was there was a video capturing
homelander murdering um you know
an innocent died and you see him just
killing like
terrorists
and
then uh he was trying to defend himself
but everyone was against him and now
here he murders someone right in front
of a crowd of people
in the states and everyone cheers him on
and so that
gives him even more free reign to now be
more sadistic and and indulge in his
more violent senses more than ever when
he's got the support of the people to
allow him to do so the people who have
motivated him validated him
and now he can keep on going
down this path and to
you know this tug of war that they'd
have with ryan i like the fliparoo of
where
last season ends with ryan choosing to
go with butcher and this season ends
with butcher and all them being saved
because ryan's the one who's pulling
homeland away and choosing to go with
homelander i think it is a good fliparoo
and it creates a more interesting
conflict of
for for someone like butcher and what a
genius way to to have the tables turn in
the heat of a moment
uh in your finale of butcher will not
let ryan die yeah he can and if he let
ryan die could have killed homeland or
they would have been in this situation
um but i think that is just clever
clever writing because ryan's kind of
been in the background a little bit
one could see i think you know one k i
would have liked to have checked in with
ryan a tad a bit more to be totally
honest there was a part of me that's
like i could have used a little bit more
of
i don't know what ellie would have done
better than that he's chilling on the
farm
like bored as hell he's just chilling
and stewing about that last moment with
butcher yeah bonnie with mallory you
know um yeah there's not much more you
could have done granted but who knows
maybe just developing the relationship
with that mallory and and this to make
that kind of
that heart-wrenching pull a little bit
more um
however i do think that's really clever
to have it turn because you you keep
wondering like is it going to be
soldier boy who ultimately succumbs to
being a father and and embracing his his
son now
is that who it's going to be and i like
the difference that the the the divide
that that is established of what he's
like calling homeland or a [ __ ] and
saying you know like you just seek this
love and stuff like he he views him as
weak
and so showing that he's not like him
that they are too they are two different
people
and in response to
how they
wish to be perceived
i think that's really great at drawing
the line there and does make it if you
feel like you're setting up for
something even more chaotic i do like
that they kept them alive i do like that
because it
there's more doors to explore
with soldier boy and you know like they
keep the way they shift the dynamics of
team-ups and enemies it's so
so invigorating the way they they do it
because they don't rely on like
nuke like there's always a new cast
member every season there's always some
new players
but this show is not
heavily reliant on that it's really just
about how do you mix things up it's not
that the key to the stakes is oh we
gotta have a new character to to you
know get you afraid that they will die
or something yeah it's they're good at
playing the chess game
and shifting around people's allegiances
and and making you wonder because
they're you know like a train is like a
perfect example of that it's like how
many experiences will it take for this
guy to finally maybe land on the right
side of anything and it doesn't seem
like at this point it will ever happen
but they're really good at
at least
convincing you that it maybe could
someday and that makes for really fun
both you know drama and
you know the lighter mo i feel like the
deep is like the more light version of
that where you're like this guy's never
gonna change this guy is gonna always be
who he is
uh and yet
i don't know they still find interesting
things to make out of that and they
still kind of hold the statuses and the
dynamics well and and you know like
losing noir this episode like that felt
pretty momentous still uh because you
know we see how powerless everybody is
and to a degree they've always been so
but uh yeah to kind of get to the end
it's like you have homelander at the top
of everything and we had noir and they
they do nicely it's like they've given
him this personality and then they've
embellished it you know they started
with the body language and they
embellished it here with the the cartoon
animals but even beyond that i just
liked
the triangle that they drew like there
was a certain closeness and admiration
between black noir
and soldier boy until that relationship
turns you know horribly sour just
because of who soldier boy is and then
you know the way that mutates into his
relationship to homelander like that
like as much as
in a way it's not one of the main main
main characters dying and maeve doesn't
actually die i still was like wow you
know for for black noir to go out like
this does feel pretty harsh and does
feel pretty momentous in this moment and
he is the one member of the team you
might actually mourn for if they died
yeah it's like no one on the seven
necessarily was a good person even black
noir was not necessarily a good person
um but he was the one you were most
sympathetic towards because the show
always did things to demonstrate his
sensitivity whether it be in season one
where he plays the piano or when he's
learning about compound b and he's he's
crying in the hallway in season two
and then here they really capitalize on
that even more but showing how he was
treated by soldier boyd with payback and
who he feels he can interact with others
like cartoon looney tunes and
animal-like friends of his
you know they really showed um just who
he really is at his at his core
that even despite he is his violent
individual
that he really is uh this thing of
sensitivity and there's like there's
frightened yeah there's like there's
still a child in there yeah he's
automatically endearing no matter how
horrible you make the character to some
extent was something about the way when
he showed up i was like i smell death on
this guy yeah
he's gonna die
and uh the second
you know he admitted fault
uh or admitted to have having kept that
as hidden from homelanders up
dude's dead right away because that's
the thing he holds that's the homelander
values most
you know and it's like the more
homelander what they've been doing with
homelanders the more they strip away
every element of facade or something
that he would
latch onto
to feel worthy
or to feel the sense of belonging the
more they do that the more they strip
those qualities away
the more he
starts to like come out of his shell the
more
the the thing that will lead to the
scorching of the earth as they put it
and i love that i love that quality so
gonna miss black noir really was a
delightful presence i feel like in some
way he could survive that still but not
part of me was wondering if they were
going to have it be that on that like
you know darth vader on a table you know
getting stitched up and and you know
either some kind of mumbo jumbo with
compound v or something with you know
mechanical parts blah blah blah but
i don't know i i honestly feel like it
could still happen but part of me is is
as much as i am bummed to see a
character go it does make things feel
real and finite so yeah i was sitting
there bargaining myself watching his
little intestines spray blood and i'm
like but he could come back from this
somehow right but well on the right now
it doesn't feel like it on the flip with
maeve i think i think her character
deserved to live
i hope that her character does not i
hope that if like i don't know what the
season plans are for season four
like is that supposed to be the final
one i know they announced that early on
with this debut of this season but they
might have the season four and five i
imagine they can go on for a while
there's many stories to draw from with
the comics but where they end off with
maeve here i think is very strong
because she's had such a defined arc
um especially from season one to now
you know and i appreciate that they
brought it back around from this season
of her training with the fighting and
then
you know she's being held prisoner so
you don't really think anything's going
to happen with it you don't really think
she i didn't actually think she'd be
like having a fight with homeland or be
able to hold her own throughout most of
it
but i thought it was a very worthy fight
like her the brutality and the
ferociousness
of her like just how she wouldn't stop
going no matter what was happening to
her no matter how injured she got and
obviously homelander was just like
holding back but he was still getting
dealt some pretty you know pretty awful
blows
throughout and then for her to
have like the ultimate sacrifice in the
in the
image
of everyone i'm surprised she live
anyway if anything i'm like i'm
surprised you survived that like you
were like up close with him at that
moment and the explosion happened
happening you fell to the ground like i
i would think you would die
um but i think you know just in terms of
like audience members association with
the character who was kind of like
frustrating to me in the beginning of
season two
who then i really started to root for
and then this whole time you know who's
just kind of been put through the ringer
and beaten and put down and all ways
to then have this moment i thought was
really rewarding and i thought that
uh they earned it i think that's the
most important thing is they earned what
she ultimately got to have in the end
i think everyone did essentially like i
like who french he's evolved into
someone more
confident and sure of himself and is
like gonna finally be able to stand up
to butcher
um
hughie
was more so coming at
realizations of what real strength is
versus the physicality side of it no
eric you kind of pissed off some people
the other day on twitter
with howie defined because someone asked
him a question about
why is it okay why would starla i think
it's okay for um kimiko
to get powers through compound v again
but wasn't okay for huey
and he answered something along the
lines of
i have to remember him totally
paraphrasing here but something along
the lines of like huey was doing it
because he wanted to feel macho
whereas kimiko was doing it because it
comes from like a sense of wanting to
protect
you know and and whatnot and take
ownership of something that you've been
so uh
you know
torn up over and and felt it was thrust
upon you unfairly yeah crippy didn't say
that um
humphrey did
cripty didn't say that it was a very
specific tweet that he put out and it
was pissing off a lot of people because
i'm like oh so
man can't take it to defend his woman
but
there's a whole bunch of context that
i'm sure he could have put in a tweet
that's not the point and also you know
v24 doesn't have the same effect does
come movie
so i i do like uh i do like what huey
ultimately learned especially that
learning lesson he does have about his
father because he he seemed to kind of
reject and judge
everything about his father never
understood him and it seemed like he
finally understood who his father was
and what strength his father actually
possessed
the even though the show would even kind
of paint him as someone who was weak
that there was actually not a lot of
weakness in what he did but a lot of
strength in what he did and i i like
that that whenever they go more gray i'm
really happy about that and them getting
to tell his daughter the truth about the
past
sounds like they don't know that soldier
boy's still alive
um
but can't do that butcher being set up
now for
he's got a timeline of when he might
when he would die i hope the show goes
through with him actually dying
i like when they commit to that [ __ ]
he's got a specific timeline here
and now he has to uh now they have to
adhere to that they're saying he's got
like 12 months to live shouldn't they
back home with some [ __ ] but every
season from now on is only four days i
mean this the time to take place and
tend to be relatively short yeah tend to
be like a few weeks you can still
squeeze a good amount of stories yeah
those last 18 months on the long end
yeah i i think this is my favorite
season um i'm not entirely sure
i don't like immediately jumping on the
bandwagon of that uh but i i think this
is my favorite one
i really i think it could easily be mine
as well i mean i think the way that this
season has both encapsulated
you know the the growth of their
combinations of the iconography and
imagery of superheroes and all that
stuff with the satire and the commentary
i feel like they've had a pretty
you know just solid grip on you know
each season they get a little more
assured about that and then this season
in particular
um it's like yeah having every episode
feel like a standalone kind of
installment and also having it be that
uh you have so many of the core ensemble
like it didn't feel like they felt
forced to have everyone together or to
you know recreate all the same dynamics
as before like there's a lot of
uh disparity between the boys between a
lot of different people there's a lot of
pairings off and whatnot and i thought
that made for yeah nice character
explorations nice confrontations and
nice moments where we have no idea
what's going to happen we feel jeopardy
for you know our core team who i guess
you could argue probably not going to
die but at least i know we sat here
every week going oh god please don't
kill french or kimiko or even mother's
milk like i i yeah i i liked the
ultimate growth and resolution yeah
frenchie stands up mm gets to sort of
legitimize
uh you know his trauma with his daughter
instead of you know trying to create
this perfect world uh yeah and everybody
like nobody felt useless or anything
like that or like they were spinning
their wheels to get you know somebody
involved like not every character is the
most integral to every episode but yeah
this felt well proportioned and well
just conceived in terms of where
everyone is and what everyone's going
through it feels like there's more to
come but also like they made a crisp
package out of this particular season
i think starlight
what's her name roddy catherine
catherine moriarty catherine moriarty i
think that's her name
forgive me if i'm wrong on that uh her
last name is moriarty
she's an incredible actress and i feel
like she's not talked about it enough
yeah you kind of just accept her kind of
the way you accept like carl urban yeah
you just accept her but she is she
is
the the way they've
developed her character and flushed her
out as this
as this you know brave individual
and someone with a sense of like true
strength possessed coming first
internally then externally i think is so
awesome of her and she's one of the
people i
moral ground wise and then physical wise
when she's around i feel like a sense of
safety and security when she's there
and uh as a leader as well how she's
really morphed into that you know like
the first season really felt like
her huey
a butcher and homelander were the main
characters
and they've they've kind of kept that
through line with her especially and i
think she's such a i don't feel like she
gets enough recognition for her
contribution to this show
she's phenomenal and she maintained
being phenomenal to me from the
beginning of the season to the very end
and the range she displays so great and
i was really worried that soldier boy
was going to kill her yeah i thought
soldier was going to get the jump on her
um
yeah excellent work there
hey train i don't know what to feel
about him i mean i i i feel like the uh
the episode could tug and pull with the
audience but i like the way they decide
to explore that and especially with the
whole
the brother being being like you
shouldn't have killed him we needed
justice to be served and we wanted to
see him locked up basically you want to
see him suffer and be punished and see
the image taken down for the public to
see exactly i see this guy's mug shot
know that he is not a good guy and
that's the retribution that the
community needed to yeah and so because
now he's gonna get that heroes send off
blah blah blah yeah
yeah um
and ashley you know like i i like the
way they paint her because
you know she's she's always
i i you i always feel how torn she is
even when she seems dead set on a
particular path but so much of what like
she has to pretty much hide or
deny
moral values
in order to
survive you know like she she's always
caught in fear and has to constantly act
off of that
and i thought the physical
representation of just how much this
tears at her you know
literally yeah of you know she pulled
out all of her hair and it just looks so
painful that she has to wear a wig like
she that's how
that's how she lets out everything she's
feeling internally and i thought that
was a really fascinating character
reveal on her end well in a way they've
co-opted it into like a kink coping
mechanism too like again like the way
they flesh and develop even characters
like that is like so twisted and
fascinating and she does a terrific job
too and i think uh you know that they
lay some type of groundwork i thought
was really clever
and and of you know
ashley number two she doesn't let go on
the helipad
and
you see that look that ashley number two
has it's like she's she's gonna remember
that
and then ashley two's with her when she
deletes the footage of maeve
and some i'm like uh you can't trust
anyone in the show
you could use that against her she could
totally use that against her in some way
if that means her climbing the ranks
yeah everyone tries to do a vaught climb
the ladder yeah even if there was an
off-screen kumbaya how long could that
last when opportunity and leverage are
applied
yeah i'm sad the seasons wrapped up but
it was an amazing journey another
knockout season for the boys rush yeah
um
not sure why i'd rank it yet but
probably my favorite now
all right guys what did you think about
this season leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe click that
notification bell leave a like thank you
to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
check us out on our podcast and whatnot
if you're already here at the podcast
thanks for being here
uh anyway let's do this for the patreon
aniso oliva anisa i've took me eight
episodes to finally get here but i'm
wearing the supernatural shirt you got
it
actually i think you got us two but but
this is the my favorite one i often get
compliments on it whenever i go out in
public or go to the gym or even in it
people are always like bitching shirts
what they always say so nisa thank you
for uh helping me out with my attire for
today getting a chance to represent it
and i want to thank you for being you
you've been
an amazing friend to us on all accounts
and an amazing listener
and
you just have this like kind of
unconditional support and love that is
really hard to find so thank you for
being with us for so long and
you know you're you're
you're above average to us
broke the bell curve
yeah you're a really special lady to us
so you're super i can't wait to hang out
with you again when you're out here in
california or when the day inevitably
comes when we finally visit texas but
thank you for being you and know that
you have our hearts with you forever
much love dear
[Music]